so what I have here is oxtail I'm just
gonna go with my fingers I don't care I
said
see so the plate that one is two people
come in two meals are swept but only one
can win who will take home the golden
fork in this week's meal swap dominican
republic versus Puerto Rico hailing from
the Dominican Republic
welcome gotta yell from Puerto Rico
welcome Eve
today we're swapping our favorite meals
I am defending the iconic the delicious
inside were also mofongo so good so
mofongo is like the most iconic thing
like every restaurant you're going Berto
Rico they have more foam boys we got
more people doing a fungus more Puerto
Rican God wants to say that is Dominican
but they got mangu they got their own
planets we got we got Paul so calm down
my dad makes bomb mofongo so every time
I have mofongo it's like a piece of home
because it's a combination of like lapa
nose and the me and the seasoning and
the liquid which is so good at Kailua
they see more than like you just pour it
all over and it's so good I don't think
I've ever had mofongo by myself which is
crazy everytime I eat my fungal it's
because I'm celebrating or going to
dinner with friends or my family so it's
always a good time
also Dominicans make mofongo too but I
gotta put that out there you know I'm
saying so what I have here is oxtail mmm
after I love boxes my mom used to make
exhale all the time I don't know what
helping so she don't make it for me
anymore so but she said make it all the
time and that was the time that me and
my family will come together and we'll
sit together we are ourselves one thing
I love about show is like it's the most
flavorful meat of the Ox the reason why
is because it's so attached to the bone
and a lot of the richness and the
flavors come from the bone so what I
have here is Axel's
Umar oh and we also have plantains fried
plantains Dominicans we love plantains
so that's a come we're able to make
fried plantains we're gonna make mofongo
so everybody make mangu it just
versatile yeah I think my dish is gonna
win because there is more flavors within
this meat then what you're gonna get
from that mofongo Wow the shape and then
you got everything is you got plant on
those too we got the oxtail do you want
the richest meat and we got rice and
beans together like this is everything
you're gonna want in food well in my
plate we got more foam girl which is
basically just like mashed plantains but
it's crispy because they they add
Teachout wrong which is pork rind and
then it's topped with betadine which is
pork and it's so juicy because I know
where there's no fungus from and I know
it's delicious and it's super juicy they
put the guy low on top it's bomb it's
just flavorful it's like a combination
of flavors exploding your mouth and
you're gonna be like whoa well with that
usually my what I said I said you'd say
that rice and beans together
all right I don't really want to but I
guess we'll swap get this tail but then
we're gonna swap back we're gonna swap
back Jersey one oxtail give me some and
don't be eating all the platinum leave
me want platinum bro yeah all these
instructions that's it that's the okay
so well leave me some meat not gonna lie
I recently had ox Hill for the first
time it was interesting cuz the taste
was okay but just the idea that it's a
tail is the thing that throws me off
that was okay you said was good it was
good it was good
don't be changing what you said last
time I was there okay but I said that
the taste was good but I also said that
I would not order it by myself this one
looks different you actually your hand
bro let me live Oh it'll go it's ready
good mm-hmm I'm gonna eat the mofongo
it smells rich I know where they got it
from some lie I know it's gonna be
delicious Triple Threat truck I know
it's coming from you so I can smell them
nothing worth but the best these people
make the best move home where I would
taste it in my life
this is really good I'm a big fan of
carne asada which is like beef stew and
this takes exactly like that it's more
flavor than ever I gotta be stupid it
also has this like a little bit of like
cajun spices in it I'm just gonna go
with my fingers I don't care the beneath
it so that it was voted for a long time
then it's nice and soft you can never go
wrong yo my man this is hard this is
rich as it is very relaxed in a good way
is extremely rich it's good but I'm done
I am ready to try my own delicious bone
put it back on the he's such a clean
freak God is the one person I will ask
in every text that did you wash these
utensils I'm surprised you didn't
yesterday you gotta ruin my move
see this is us so good it brings back
joy and memories I would have some mayo
ketchup which is man isn't ketchup mixed
together and you would like pour it all
over I gotta stay with my mph on boom
that is a little bit of an acquired
taste also it's like something that not
everyone's like immediately like oh I'm
gonna order an oxtail like oh I can't
wait to your tail speak about yourself
bro a lot of people just go out and eat
Axew
I said especially for Caribbeans will go
nuts basu people go nuts for mofongo -
and you can't find it and like
everywhere like we're lucky we got a
Twitter even food a bagel as nuts from a
phone quest oh yeah tasting it back to
back even though he ruined my mail
delicious I love my gosh - I love my
side I'll do anything like I'll travel
far away
cocktails almost every day got it or not
I still like obsessed fanatic I love
crazy about it the answer is always so
fruit flavorful so juicy I love the me I
love the meat comes out of the bone but
Ian it back to back with a mofongo I
think I will go further more for me
that's me being honest the reason why is
the way was prepared was super super
rich it's not a lot of people make more
fun with like that if I have to sit with
a player of oxtails and this mofongo
I'll go with that more I'm gonna be
honest I will be interested in eating
mofongo with oxtail on top that's a good
idea
you should come up with own restaurant
I'm a fungal made out of oxtail that's a
good idea
that would be bomb I still stand by the
case of I prefer mofongo only because I
am a true mofongo fan but Brenda - back
to back well the difference I feel like
it's a lot
I think we're ready for our final
decision
thank Axl was really good also because
I've had it before I was already like
anticipating what I was gonna eat at
first I was scared but I really think
that oxtail is one of those foods that
you eat once in a while or not everyone
at least I personally wouldn't want to
eat ox Hill every single week every day
every day I eat them oh yeah like god
yeah it's just a true fan I'm the same
way like God but with my phone go where
I could even phone go every two days and
I would be happy I could do that too he
can eat anything I'm not too crazy about
more formula and beyond to be honest but
I know what this mofongo comes from and
this mofongo
is probably one of the best performers
that has ever made like is delicious it
was a hard decision
you know it was a really hard decision
but we both had to come with a
conclusion and we needed to be fair and
honest am i right yes so the plate that
one is more fun go first oh there you go
yo my Dominicans I know you're gonna be
a little mad at me but the thing is the
people that made this mofongo make it so
delicious and ridiculous it's just like
there's no comparison I know it's like
they put something in their food and
makes it like more richer I don't know
what it is like they had it's a home for
flavor like if it was a regular mofongo
I think doctor wouldn't want you know
that's what I think maybe I don't know
but I want like to thank my mom for she
named ependymoma fungo when I was little
I would like to thank Triple Threat food
truck or serving this mofongo but the
only reason why you want I would like to
thank God for he didn't make it remains
appear in the earth okay
[Music]